President Trump did not appear in public
over the weekend to address the crisis
he did speak out on Twitter a senior
advisor tell CBS News some of the
president's aides and allies outside the
White House have urged him to scale back
the daily briefings on the corona virus
has been Tracie reports one of the
president's top scientific advisors says
testing still needs to be dramatically
improved we have to have a breakthrough
innovation and testing dr. deborah birx
has a different type of coronavirus test
similar to those that test for flu is
needed to adequately screen the US
population a so-called antigen test
would more quickly and cheaply detect
the body's response to the virus
just allows you to screen large numbers
of individuals quickly Burks also said
the White House is working with States
to increase testing capacity
despite the president saying states are
responsible for their own testing and
bragging about the overall US response
we've tested far more than anybody else
anywhere in the world the president is
now often contradicted by his own health
experts and even some in his own party
are criticizing his daily press
briefings unfortunately some of the
messaging has not been great Maryland
governor Larry Hogan a Republican says
his state's emergency management agency
was flooded with calls after President
Trump said this on Thursday I see the
disinfectant in a minute and is there a
way we can do something like that
injection I think it's critical that the
President of the United States when
people are really scared and in the
middle of this worldwide pandemic that
in these press conferences that we
really get the facts out there after the
blowback this weekend on Twitter the
president questioned the purpose of
having White House news conferences
adding not worth the time and effort but
it's his own comments that have forced
his team to spend time clarified and dr.
Burks expressed her frustration with the
media coverage sometimes I worry that we
don't get the information to the
American
people that they need when we continue
to bring up something that was from
Thursday night CBS News has learned that
the White House now plans to focus more
on the economy in its messaging and that
public health information from dr. Burks
and dr. Anthony Falchi will take a
backseat to that now there is a press
briefing scheduled here at the White
House for this afternoon but it's
unclear if the president will attempt
Tony alright Ben Tracy for us at the Ben
thank you very much